i personally think timing is everything
and this song couldn't be teed up at a
better time
i wish that i'd have been the friend
that billy never knew
i think it's time to come together you
and i
can make change i think when we
when we recorded it and when i wrote it
we were already at a time of
um you know division and animosity and
you know hatred and all the things that
we
are against you know and i had no idea
that you know come
come january this song would be hitting
the airwaves and honestly it would be
even more
needed in january than it was in october
it's not beating anybody up and it's not
political and it's not any of those
sorts of things it's all about
positivity and it's all about
you know just sort of taking a step back
and finding the positive and the
goodness
that we all have and it's more about
social
social fabric that we all rely on and
the social
contracts that we all rely on that hold
us together
and keep us sort of tethered to each
other in a positive way and that's what
this song's about
and when we gonna learn to try on
someone's shoes sometimes
when we gonna start to see from someone
else's eyes
i think it's time to come together you
and i
can make a change i've kept the tv off
for the last couple weeks but i still
caught the news about the capital and
it's just so sad but it did remind me
like okay this message is still needed
you know it's not 2021 hit and all of a
sudden everyone's unified again i mean
we really
we're still uh you know it's gonna take
some time to rebuild and to uh
you know repair